oh nice on the way
oh wow full body burn there's most that
just turn very like tv action where it
just feels like they had no time
this part's so fun and ridiculous
do you want to hear all the secrets oh
yes yes i would love to hear all the
secrets okay
thanks to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video stick around to the end to
see how you can spruce up your
creativity
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of stunt women react we are here
with cassandra ebner who has made the
trek all the way down from canada to
join us she might be also working other
things out here in la but you know
whatever she came that she came down
here first i came to see you
she has worked on game of thrones shazam
flash all you guys that love cw shows
the heroes she's probably working with
them i used to make my own films when i
was 13 years old and then continued on
and used to be a youtuber and then i
wanted to be a stunt woman because i
watched youtube videos and saw these
amazing stunt women like zoe belle and
dana grant from new zealand and i was
like they are the coolest people i know
i want to be like them one day and uh
yeah i've just been bouncing around i
was just on disney's peter pan and wendy
that's super cool oh yeah nice to meet
you
sounds like a pretty solid career thank
you
well uh cassandra's got a bunch of
really cool stuff so let's jump into
some of these clips and you can break
down what you've done the crazy stories
you might have and we'll go from there i
think it's gonna be a great episode
let's do it
are you in the bus i'm in the bus i'm a
passenger right now i'm like way at the
back did you guys actually have a set
turned vertically yeah oh cool
that's neat oh
so they drop you all the way down like a
vertical bus set so
do you want to hear all the secrets oh
yeah yes i would love to hear all the
secrets okay so this was super cool the
special effects team on this show is
amazing so this was i think an old
roller coaster that they used and
mounted a bus onto it and the bus came
over and then could go vertical like
this oh wow
physical up down
back on back yeah and they could do it
at like certain speeds they could move
it up and down and so like you could
have it like go slow where it was like
doing the inch
or you could go super fast down he could
make it go all the way down like close
to the ground so that they could film
everything close up as well that's tight
yeah it was like one of the coolest rigs
i've ever been on so how did you do the
fall through the bus like that um all
the three people who were falling they
rigged us in there and um we were on
descenders they just like slowed down
the fall right before we hit the fun
thing about this one is they both got to
go down the middle because they're like
normal heights right you had to go
through
so i was like
do not move do not move and i couldn't
hit the railings but you see like one of
the railings right yep that right there
that seat part like comes up and so i
had to think small and it already am
small so it was tight i think i was on
probably two lines yeah but because i
was on two lines and then one yeah if
you move it all you swipe
so you have to make sure that you don't
sway at all or then you're like bouncing
back and forth that's not fun yeah fun
to do so yeah
yeah
hitting the window hitting the railing
and then you're just like spinning and
it's not a good time how do you keep
your head from just snapping backwards
um tuck your chin you wouldn't want to
like pike up like this because then you
would whip your head back so like you
kind of want to try and leave your back
flat but tuck your chin and then you
would hit with your shoulders first and
then bring your head back someone else
might tell you something different but
that's how i would that's how i would do
it yeah yeah i agree thank you i like
having you here so you can like
i'm like yeah you're absolutely right
yeah for sure he said i was right so
verified
[Music]
we were all hired as stunt actors in
this that's a cool thing sometimes about
hiring people who like to be in scenes
and and create those moments is you can
make any person do whatever you want a
lot of stuff they cut out but they did
like close-ups of us like freaking out
on the bus and the director's like now
say like no my i need to see my daughter
or something and so they would just like
make us say a bunch of stuff so they
could plug it in to wherever they wanted
if they needed it i haven't feel you can
get really good acting moments from
stunt performers in these situations
because you're already immersed in it
you don't really have to act all the
time you just like ah and it's like that
was very natural how did you get there
it's like well i was falling
indeed
to save the universe absolutely
classic tomb raider movie i love this
movie i don't care anybody says some of
the gravity doesn't really make sense in
this but i love it
i love it when they can't shoot
like she's like right there
he's like i'm shooting for i'm shooting
guys
this part is so fun and ridiculous how
is that guy digging from the ceiling
spinning to follow her there's a lot of
physics questions in this scene but it's
really cool it gets up to him though do
you think they're using actual bungee or
like stretchable cords for this scene or
do you think they're just dressing it to
look like that it's actually people
pulling you know rigs and pulleys and
ropes to like looks like bungee but then
there's some moments where they slow it
down
i think it's a mixture of both yeah for
those moments like the acting beats but
it looks so good like whatever they put
on the wires it like to sell it right
yeah what kind of like fitness do you
need to be able to have for a wire work
personally for me what i like to do is i
really try to have good core good back
strength and when i was training a bunch
of kids for wire work i would always do
like these really fun exercises where
you're like doing planks to get their
like core strength going but once they
got like better at that i would do these
like is it okay if i do a little
exercise on the ground yeah yeah i would
do something where you would like get
into the boat position
and then you'd roll over
and do this and then just keep going and
then go back and forth and then i also
like to do those exercises because
they're kind of fun too
i
loved lara croft so much that i wanted
to make a laircraft anything we filmed
it i think it was in total 11 days and
we didn't have much light we shot it in
vancouver
and doing fight scenes around rocks is
always scary yes
the tackle of the rock's pretty
impressive too i think i accidentally
need him in the balls there
man i'm so sorry i remember him being
like oh i was like i'm so sorry but i
had to use his body there that was all
practical
you just got slammed there this is scary
because you're like there's rocks all
around and there's roots all around i
mean you have a tank top on did that
hurt so actually the director of this is
also a stunt coordinator so he knew what
he needed so we looked around the forest
for like a flat spot that looked great
with a bunch of rocks around we took a
shovel to the ground and chopped it up a
bit so that the fall wouldn't be
as bad and then i could put hip pads in
probably a little bit of a tailbone and
then you just commit and then they film
like a little bit down to up and then it
looks like a bigger yep but he's six
feet so it is also it's it's a big round
does he try to slow you down at all
right before you hit or is it just say
here you go have fun usually like all
the performers when you're you're
working with them it's a dance together
so they'll try to help save you if they
can but sometimes it's just commit
because you just want to get the shot
done yeah you don't want to do it 7000
times his job was like i'm just going to
make sure you don't land on the rock you
don't land on your head yes you can make
sure you land flat exactly how did you
not get all scratched up from the rocks
um i
did yeah
there's a leading question yeah that's
the funny part about sometimes when
you're a girl you don't get a lot of
great outfits this was based off the
video game so thanks for that guys who
made the video game in her costume
but it's okay like sometimes it looks
really cool like i understand you get a
little bit of a gun show sometimes now i
get to wear more stuff
like jackets and stuff so i can hide
more to be a stunt woman is tough you
have to wear the same thing as the
actress but then you have to fight in a
rocky area with a whole bunch of guys so
you're tough you're really tough like i
give you your props and people need to
understand that being a stunt woman in
this industry is not easy us guys we get
to wear jackets all the time back pads
what are those right
you don't get to wear elbows you don't
get to wear a backpack sometimes you
don't even get to wear knees if they put
you in a skirt or a dress yeah you know
so i actually i did a car hit in a dress
that guy was like damn you want to dance
oh man all of that was practical and
real when you're getting hit by a car
fun facts you want to try and be on your
toes so that the car lifts you up if you
don't then you are going to be punted to
the ground and then go under the car i'm
already on my toes because i'm in
massive heels that were so hard to walk
in my friends all made fun of me for it
so i'm on my toes but i want to be light
on my feet so that when the car comes
i'm ready but as you can see i had to do
a car hit from behind and then as i feel
the car coming i know it's like i think
we counted out the cars that would go
beside me and then when the person was
behind me so if there was like one two
three i knew they were coming so then i
could peek over my shoulder to see the
hood so i could get up onto it so when
it comes to pads as you can see
not wearing much but the stunt
coordinator was awesome he made sure
that my elbows were covered so that i
could put elbows on i also did it twice
oh wow yeah so the first time they said
the car didn't look like it was going
fast enough for it to kill me so they
wanted it a second time and the second
time they did it my shoe flew off 60
feet behind camera they believed it then
yeah
but i think on the second take my head
actually hits the window and it cracks
the window a little bit oh yeah but i
was okay because what i was wearing was
like a hair piece and then the
coordinator asked to slip a little um
not a pad it was actually like a like a
hard shell that was like shaped to my
skull that's cool so he put it
underneath and i'm really grateful for
that because it could have gone really
badly if i didn't have that shout out to
the stunt coordinator yeah
don't feel fooled will you release
russell prime
are you yeah it's me again
i do a lot of acting you have a lot of
different looks yeah that's dope i'm a
chameleon for the glory and the grace
of the primes
oh wow full body burn wow
standing still
so when you run with a full body burn
the flames can get out of your face or
like away from you but with standing
still the flames just kind of burn in
one spot what do they want to do baby
one of the cool things was they they
considered that and they had like a tiny
little fan kind of blowing on me so that
at least it could try to relieve some of
the flames in the one same spot all the
time and i'm doused in a bunch of gel
that's why i look so wet i had a really
great fire team walk us all through it
and it was really great super safe you
know all the procedures of what you need
to do if the flame starts licking you is
the term that they use
so it's like where it actually hits your
skin a little bit and you feel it you
have to go down right away because that
means you're just about done done yeah
we did it first with my face exposed
with a bunch of gel on it and then the
second time we actually put like a mask
on so that i could go for longer because
it keeps the gel on your face longer it
like kind of came down my face a little
bit and then it started to lick my neck
a little yeah so then i had to go down a
little bit sooner than i would have if i
did have a mask on yeah for sure
probably made your character kind of
like splattered with water or something
before the scene so that's a natural
blend right yeah that's exactly what's
their intentions so kind of universal
symbol for put me out please is being on
the ground but you have to go to the
ground for the scene here yeah so how do
they know when to come in and put you
out for the first fire burn that was the
symbol if i went to the ground because
they just wanted me to do the first part
of the scene if i went to the ground it
meant i was done so then for the second
part of the scene if i needed to be put
out i think it was like raise your hand
but honestly i
could have burned there for so long like
i had so much gel on me i was totally
fine so they actually put me out on
their own time interesting because i
thought this was actually one big burn
but it's two it's two two gotcha that
makes sense now because then you're on
the ground they can just do your back
and now it's a lot less of a big deal
exactly okay yeah movie magic
this is my wild card here i would like
us to watch it and take a look at it and
maybe constructively critique it okay
let's go
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh she has like feet for hands right
yeah yeah yeah i remember now
she's crawling whoa she crawls so fast
man the hand feed thing oh no ah that
hurts
good for your feet
we just had tumble tracks and just hired
gymnasts yeah oh
but that is amazing that she was able to
do that yeah
so think about anflex it's like there's
cool ideas in there there's cool style
in there and there's moments that are
cool and there's moments that just turn
very like tv action where it just feels
like they had no time or like a way to
glue their moments together yeah i don't
mean this and like i'm trying to [ __ ] on
people kind of way art deserves
critiques sometimes in fact as an artist
myself getting good analytical critiques
is one of my favorite things to get it's
so rare to get that you know for me for
example here when they're running
they're being shot at they're just
running right there's like head turns
but that's not a dodge you know yeah
immediately calls in the question like
are these weapons even effective
depending on like when you're looking at
the script and trying to figure out what
kind of action you want to put in there
to suit the story not just as a stunt
coordinator not just as the director not
just as the editor just everybody in
general should be remembering what's
happening they're dodging what does that
mean does it mean that they're sliding
on the ground and then getting up and
then dodging to the right falling
somewhere getting back up like what does
that action look like and making sure
everybody's on the same page also have
been cool to see
if you didn't dodge it what it would do
yeah true because then it would add a
little bit more danger aspect because
yeah you see it hit the tree and then
there's some sort of liquid that goes
and what does that mean right another
weird thing is when forehands lady
there's like a bar right here and she's
coming at it kind of with like a front
flip spin yeah and so if her feet were
to catch that the next thing would be
under it yep yeah it changed right there
yeah she was going to fly away and then
turned into her doing her flip and it's
probably just a shot of her hands
yeah yeah for sure but the same thing is
like they've removed the contacts so
they're hiding the actress's body but
now the audience can't immediately tell
these are supposed to be her feet yeah
like you need to see her knees at least
be like okay that's her feet that we're
looking at we were focusing in that last
shot before this we're focusing on our
upper body this is where our brains are
going oh where is she going we're
looking at the top of her and one of the
things is people talk about the action
being in the middle of the screen so
right now we just think this is all
about her and her hands sometimes you
have to overlap the action in order for
us to make sense of what's happening so
if they actually had overlapped things
and then actually put the action in the
middle of the frame we'd be able to
understand what's happening there i've
heard a good saying that the first three
frames of any cut like when you cut to a
shot those first three frames do not
register for people so you can't have
anything those first three frames that's
important you need to get through those
and then you can finally start
delivering information again a lot of
time camera operators that are filming
action haven't come from a world of
picture-based storytelling this might
sound weird but if you're a
cinematographer or even an action
designer you understand how emotion is
going to sell a movement but a lot of
time camera operators are coming into
the world from like the assistant camera
side of things so they're not studying
you know how to do kinetic editing right
and like how to suggest things with
camera motion like that's the action the
price job yeah but there's moments in
here where like charlie's thrown is
doing a flip and it cuts like a pov
camera move to like kind of sell motion
but then it's spinning sideways and it's
just another one of those weird
decisions let's say i'm in the direction
like all right cassandra we have a scene
where she needs to do her like signature
crawl but she's going so fast she's
dodging these things how would you build
that how would you try to execute that
to make it look i think the concept that
they were trying to do it's there
physically and maybe for the the wire
maybe put some give into it because
she's very flat it doesn't look like
she's holding her body there's no weight
yeah it just looks so fake like she
almost looks like she's flying but for
some reason she's moving she's using her
arms and legs just for the sake of this
yeah that's the perfect counter motion
shot you know going this way and the
camera going this way so it like makes
it look like you're playing twice as
fast yeah but maybe that's what they
were going for like it looks like
they're trying to go for like a matrix
style thing if they filmed it more anime
style it might suit the action a little
bit more right but hey you know profits
release their own for doing the crazy
wire work there yeah for sure at least
for some of the shots
dude i really want some eyebrows that i
can like fold into my hairline
do the ganondorf eyebrows yes please
that's like my worst nightmare
oh he's in the canoe
all right oh that's tight oh sick
this is actually really i'm i'm enjoying
this this is tight so is he like pushing
it with his feet right like how how the
hell are they doing a little yingling
damn look at that impact the dust i need
to watch this what happened to cinema
this is what cinema used to be we are
missing this he has fire on his feet oh
wait i thought they were on his head it
was on his head it's car versus canoe
his greatest weapon
i set his ears for my canoe technique
oh nice on the way
not his other leg he needs that
if i grab food out of the fridge
i want the apple
[Music]
that's the end of the clip but what
happens does he go on fire i've never
done that reaction but i love that old
like hong kong cinema fall where you
like fall on your back
yeah yeah that impact is nice though
yeah and he has his pad connected to him
oh wait is that the yeah
yeah yeah oh it is a pillow you're right
yeah it's the biggest pillow on his butt
which also explains why it looks like it
would be a really painful like fall onto
his tailbone there was one part here
where like the wires were so intense
like he's like actually climbing up the
pole like right here this part and he's
like oh just kidding
so we just saw a drunken dragon the
little man in the canoe fight and you
guys brought that to us in the comments
so please keep hitting us with those
amazing clips in the comments down below
and we'll be sure to check them out and
we'll share them with you guys
oh hey you know sometimes when things
get a little crazy i like to just chill
out here in my my really janky holodeck
i just put some storyblocks video clips
on this tv behind me and i sit really
close to it so i can't see the edges
it's like i'm there so hey you make
videos you edit videos sometimes you
need that shot and you really don't want
to get a whole crew together just go and
get that one shot or you're like ah we
need to say that this is in paris but i
really can't go to paris right now well
storyblocks has you covered they have
little bits of clips for all the kind of
different things you might need to
illustrate your videos they also have
royalty-free music and a whole bunch of
other great elements see this beautiful
sunset that we're just chilling in front
of well this is royalty free whoa now
we're in the water this is royalty free
so that means you can use it however you
want commercial personal use so we
actually use storyblocks all the time on
this channel you probably see them pop
up in quarter crew videos we pictures
react videos anytime we're telling a
story it's honestly really great for
independent creators like us so just
guys check them out we've got pricing
for all different budget levels they
even have an unlimited pass you can
download as many of these as you want
they also have subscription tiers for
all the different prices for what works
for you so if you're a big old studio
well they got you covered and if you're
just a single independent creator they
got plans for you as well so yeah you
interested well my marshmallow is almost
ready so i'll make it easy for you
there's a link down in the description
below storyblocks.com
crew you can click there and go get
started go check it out
those are big marshmallows they're the
sizes of my hand
if you guys enjoyed learning from
cassandra here well she actually has a
cool action comedy web series that she
did called life xp we'll have a link
down in the description below if you
enjoyed this go check it out give her a
shout out in the comments there tell her
that she was awesome on this show and uh
you can follow her instagram
cassandra.evening yeah xander.ebner
instagram twitter
you find me on facebook
wherever and subscribe or else a really
short person might come after you
all right sarah thank you so much thank
you appreciate you so much thank you it
was nice to meet you guys let's see you
guys the next one peace